LEAF PETERSEN: I should
mention that Bob is
the co-author on these slides.
So if they look good,
it's because of him.
But if they start
changing behind me,
I'd appreciate it if someone
would smack him, and tell
him to stop.
OK, so I hope he took
away from the keynotes
that there are a lot of very
exciting things happening
in Dart this year.
There's all sorts of
exciting things happening.
But the one that I personally
am most excited about because I
work on the language is the
fact that Dart 2 is happening.
So I want to talk today a little
bit about where we came from.
How we got to this
point of Dart 3,
where we came from,
where we are now.
And a little bit about where
we see the language going
in the future.
So I want to talk about a
process of language evolution,
and how we've been
managing that process
over the past few years.
So let's start with origins.
Our origins in the
primordial slime as it were.
So the original vision
for Dart, I think
was a very strong
and very clear one.
So sometime around
2011, there was
this idea of making a
new browser language.
A new language, a
better language,
for writing large
web applications.
So this was the
vision of Dart, and I
think it was a very strong
one in a lot of ways.
So the idea was to have
a mostly dynamic language
layer over the top of that,
sort of a Lint like type system
that also provided you
some runtime type checking,
but still allowed you
to be basically dynamic
at the heart of it.
So a mostly dynamic language
running in the browser,
and running essentially
over a just in time compiled
environment.
So one of the key
ideas behind Dart,
or one of the key
properties of it
was that it was a
language that was
designed to be great on a JIT.
Without too much concern
about making sure
that the language was easy
to compile ahead of time.
So this is a very
strong vision I think.
There was a lot to
like about this,
and we had a lot of success
in getting some very large
customers on there.
So you already heard and
saw an example of Edwards.
People writing very, very large,
very powerful applications,
and shipping them on the
web being very productive
in the language getting very
good performance out the end.
And basically, being very
happy customers for us.
But things started to
change over the time
that we were developing Dart.
So I think there was a very
large shift in the model of how
we were going to be
delivering applications
on mobile as mobile became
more and more important.
And a decision was made
not to put native to Dart
support in Chrome, so
both of those facts
changed the
environment for Dart.
So from a language which could
rely on always running on JITed
platform, we were
moving to a language
where all of our
important customers
were shipping on ahead of
time complied platforms.
So our web platform needed to
rely on a compile to JavaScript
story in order to
ship their code.
If we were going
to compile to iOS,
we needed to be able
to do good, fast,
ahead of time compilation.
So we could no longer
assume that we were always
going to be running
on a JIT where
lots of interesting
things are possible,
so there was a sense that
maybe the world was changing.
And that maybe we needed
to evolve with it,
and we needed to
think about how we
needed to change going forward.
[INAUDIBLE] today about what
that process looked like.
So one of the
experiments that we
did as we were doing
this exploration
was an idea we
called strong mode.
So the idea was can we take this
Lint like type system that's
been layered over the
sort of underlying
dynamic language of
Dart, and tighten it
up just a little bit.
Just enough to get a sort
of a soundness property.
To get the property that
you as a programmer,
and I, as a tool
developer, could both rely
on the contracts specified by
types to generate better code,
or to be more productive
if I'm a developer.
So this notion that we could
use a stronger type system
to get a good modular
compiler generating good
readable JavaScript
very, very quickly.
And at the same time,
maybe provide more value
to our developers who are
shipping very large apps
So we set out to
do this experiment,
and it was, I think, a
very interesting one.
So we went off,
and we said, what
do we need to
build a modern type
system that will support this?
So there wasn't all
that much we had to add,
so we built in some
type inference.
We changed the subtyping
rules a little bit,
changed the override
restrictions.
Basically, did
the things that we
needed to do to make sure that
you couldn't cheat the type
system anymore just enough.
We built this prototype,
and this, I think,
is the most interesting part
of the whole process for me,
and the exciting part.
And I think one of the reasons
that this experiment was
successful is that once we built
the prototype, we didn't say,
OK, we're done now.
We didn't say we've
built this thing.
Here it is.
Take it.
We had millions of lines of
existing Dart code out there,
and we just started throwing
this at our prototype.
So there was this
very data driven
process of taking feedback
from the actual code
that people had written in
Dart when it was a mostly
dynamic language with a sort
of a Lint like type system,
and saying, what do we need
to do in the type system
to support the kind of code
that people actually wrote?
And there were a lot of changes
we made to the type system
over the course of this.
The first iteration
of our type system,
we tried out using
invariant generics,
and we found there was just
too much code out there
that was using covariance.
And so we said, all right.
We went back to
the drawing board,
and figured out how we could
support covariant generics
going forward.
So this iterative process
of figuring out what worked
and what didn't work, and
supporting existing Dart code
gave us insights into
what a type system
should look like for Dart.
So
I think there is
a lot of evidence.
There was a lot of evidence
that this was successful.
So certainly from a technical
standpoint, the original goals
that we set out to accomplish,
we showed they were feasible.
So we were able to achieve
a very fast modular compile
and get a very good
dev refresh cycle.
So we were actually able to
improve the refresh cycle
for our web customers,
even though we
were moving to an
ahead of time compiled
scenario, which is
very impressive.
And at the same time, we were
able to give better error
checking through type
inference, and through sounder
checking on the types.
And so we had a lot of feedback
from people that they really
liked using this
new type system.
That it wasn't a huge burden.
That it was actually a benefit.
Interestingly,
this was true even
for people who were not getting
the benefits of a new tooling
that we were building
based on this type system.
Flutter was one of our very
early adopters on this,
and they were simply using
strong mode because they
liked the better checking.
So this was, I think, a
very good indicator to us
that we were on the right track.
We were able to get better
ahead of time compilation.
We believed that
this would carry over
to mobile to the
native, and certainly we
were seeing this on the web.
So we had this evidence that we
were able to take a language,
and make it great both for
ahead of time compilation
and for just in
time compilation.
Get the best of both worlds,
and get all the benefits
of a sound type system
without taking away
all the fun things about Dart.
So we felt this was
really a great story,
and the decision was
made to adopt this
as the core of Dart 2.
So that's great.
I think if you look at Dart
2 right now, the biggest
change that is coming,
and I think most of you
have been working
with strong mode,
so you're pretty familiar
with what the core of it is.
The biggest change
that is coming
is this strong type system,
this sound type system.
But there's a lot
of things that go
into taking a
prototype like that,
and making it actual real,
and making it usable.
So there are changes
to the tooling.
I think people are going
to talk about there's
a huge amount of
changes that needed
to happen in the ecosystem.
So many of you out there have
been contributing so much to us
as we've been
migrating this forward.
Thank you so much.
And at the same time,
there are a lot of changes
around the language
and the libraries
that we needed to
make in order to make
your experience with
working with this sound type
system great.
And so I want to
talk a little bit
about what that looked like.
What you should expect
to see in Dart 2
from the language
and the library
as it's going to make working
with these things better.
And how you can take
advantage of them.
So when I think
about the changes
that we made to the
language and the libraries
around the edges of
the sound type system,
I think there are two
key things we were trying
to enable for our developers.
And the first is we wanted
to make it easy for you
to stay statically typed.
So any place where
you were writing code,
and you had something which
was nicely statically typed,
and you wanted to
do something to it.
And you were having trouble
preserving the types
across that operation,
that was a sign
that we needed to add
something to the language.
And the second is we
wanted to make sure
that you were able to write
APIs, which worked great
with type inference.
So that if you're
writing a library,
the developers who use your
library, your consumers,
don't need to think
as much about types.
They can continue to write
their code just as they always
have been, and they get
a really nice experience
while simultaneously
getting all the benefits
of the static typing.
So I want to give a couple
of concrete examples of this
to give an idea of how this
played out in the language.
So this is kind of a core
piece of the Dart API.
This is a Dart 1 API for
the map function on list,
iterable as well.
So in Dart 1, there's this
map method on the list type.
And the key thing I want
you to notice about this
is that the return type of
the callback that you're
mapping over the elements of
this list is marked as dynamic.
So there's no
information about what
the type of things
coming out of it
are, and the type of the
iterable that you get out also
has no information about what
the type of its elements are.
So it's an iterable of dynamic.
A consequence of
this is the code
like what I have written on the
bottom there is not going to be
detected statically in Dart 1.
So you can take a list of
strings, map something over it
that tries to add one to it.
There is nothing
in the system that
will tell you that that's a
bad idea until it blows up
at run time.
So we can fix this fairly
easily without changing anything
core in the language other
than the type system in Dart 2
by adding some type inference.
So in Dart 2 we
added type inference,
so that variable,
x, in the callback
no longer is
interpreted as dynamic.
It is now inferred
to have type string,
and we're able to give you an
error here telling you, hey,
this is not a good idea.
You don't want to
add one to a string,
and you can fix your code.
The problem is this
is still an error.
This is still bad
code in Dart 2.
And the reason
is, as I mentioned
before, this map function, this
map method doesn't give you
enough information about how
types flow from the inputs
to the outputs.
Right, so the return type
of this whole operation
is an iterable of dynamic.
And in a sound type
system, we can't
allow you to put an
iterable of dynamic
in an iterable of string, right?
Because, in fact, here,
this has ints in it.
And I can't let
you put ints where
strings are expected if I want
to have a sound type system.
The solution to this then
was to change the language.
So you are having trouble as
a programmer preserving types
across an API boundary.
That means there's something in
the language that is missing,
so we added very early on
in the strong mode process.
We realized we needed to
add generic methods to Dart
because it was the only way
that we could preserve types
across these API boundaries.
So if you add this generic
type parameter to map,
now you are able
to express the fact
that the return
type of the callback
flows through and out
to the result type.
And tells you exactly what
the return type of the map
should be.
And so now you're able to
write your code in a way that
works in a sound type system.
Even better though, you
don't have to actually write
all of those types.
So this gets to the second part.
So this addition
of generic methods
is great because it allows
you to preserve the types.
But it's also great
because it allows you
as a library designer,
or in this case, us,
as core library
designers, to express
in the type of the
method in the API
exactly how inference
should work with this.
And therefore, you
are able to leave.
You, the developer
at the end, is
able to leave all of the
types off of their code
just as if they were working
in a dynamic language here.
And we we're able
to fill in the types
for them using
this generic method
schema that was laid out there.
So these two ideas of
preserving the type information,
and making the API
friendly to inference
play out very nicely here
once you add generic methods
to the language.
So this is a big feature
that we're adding to Dart 2.
And part of what we're doing is
walking through the libraries,
and looking for where do
these things need to happen.
So another great example of this
process is in the async APIs.
This at first looks extremely
similar to the example
that I just gave, right?
So here we have the
.then method on future,
which is basically
a map over futures.
And in Dart 1 as before, the
callback that you passed in
was typed to return dynamic.
And it returned a future
of some unknown type,
and so you had the same problem
with getting the information
out the other side.
So you say, OK, great.
We have a solution to this.
We make this method generic,
and life is great, right?
Generic methods for the win.
And it does, in fact, solve
this particular problem,
so it's great.
Generic methods
got us a long way.
And so when we first were
going through this process
of taking all of
this code out there,
and throwing it
at our prototype,
we had added generic methods.
We said great.
We've solved the problem
right, and we very quickly
started discovering that, no, we
hadn't solved all the problems.
And async in
particular was a place
where we encountered
something we had not expected.
And something that
we would not have
known about that we would not
have known to do if we had not
gone through this data
driven process of trying
to look at lots and
lots of real code,
and understand
what it was doing.
So why is that?
Well, the reason is that there
is this very nice pattern
that API designers
were using in Dart.
So they were basically
taking this idea of dynamic,
and using dynamic as a
kind of a union type.
So they were saying
in async code,
I often want to be able
to use the same code
with async and nonasnyc things.
So before I was passing here a
synchronous function to .then,
so it's something that
returns an integer.
But I may want to
use in the same place
a callback which is
async, and therefore,
returns a future event.
Well, that doesn't work
anymore here, right?
Because this generic
method type that I gave
says whatever the
callback type is,
I'm supposed to return
a future of that.
So this is going to be
a future, future event.
That doesn't match up.
So when we looked
at real code, when
we went out and saw
what people are doing,
we saw something very
reasonable that real developers
were using that made a great
API in which we couldn't type.
And so that was a
signal to us that we
needed to go back
to the drawing board
and add something
to the language.
So this was something that has
recently added to the language
to make async code.
Which is a very pervasive
pattern of code in Dart, great.
So FutureOr is a new type in
Dart which has been added,
which expresses this
simple union type.
So if you have a
FutureOr of cat,
that means either
you have a cat,
or you have a future of cat.
You can ask, you know so
Dart allows you to check.
Am I a future, or am I a cat?
So you can tell at runtime,
so the API inside of it
can figure it out.
And you can write
all of your APIs
to consume either one to be
convenient for your developers.
So now the right type
for future .then,
the one that actually captures
the usage patterns of real
programs is to say that the
callback doesn't return s.
And it doesn't
return future of s.
It returns future, or s.
It's allowed to
return either one,
and now you can
use it very freely.
I can call future .then
with a synchronous function.
I can call future .then with
an asynchronous function.
It all works.
The types get passed
through, and inference
works out just great for
you because, again, we've
incorporated into
the type system
an actual encoding of
the developers intent.
So this is basically
the theme, I think,
of about the past
years work that we've
spent on the language
of around the boundaries
of the sound type system.
So we added generic
methods very early on.
We added the FutureOr type
to capture these patterns
and asynchronous code.
We've added the ability to
use void as a first class type
as a type argument.
So that when you're
working with code
that return, and
say future of void,
you can continue to chain
things through in a nice way.
An inference can just
propagate that void,
and we can catch places where
you might be using a void value
unintentionally.
Another sort of empirical
thing we discovered
was that a lot of places
where people were writing
dynamic code, it was because
it was just too much of a pain
to write say a function type.
So you can always write a
typedef for a function type
somewhere else.
But if you just have
some local variable,
and you're trying to
put a function in it,
it's kind of a
nuisance to introduce
this typedef at the top level.
So adding inline function types
with something that helped us
encourage people to
make it easy for them
to write strongly typed code.
We also added null as a bottom.
This is a fairly
esoteric feature,
but there are a few places where
this enables some patterns that
were hard to write otherwise.
So the story here is basically
about taking these new features
that are designed to make
working with strong mode great,
and incorporating them into
the libraries in a way that
makes the developer
experience great to work with.
So that's all
around the language.
I want to talk a little bit
about some of the changes
we're making to the
libraries for strong mode to,
and why we're doing
what we're doing.
So this is an
example of something
that you were able
to do in Dart 1 that
was harder to do in Dart 2.
So I mentioned before
that Dart 1 allowed
you to use a list of dynamic.
Dynamic was kind of a magic
get out of jail card, right?
So you could use a list
of dynamic anywhere
you would use anything else.
So you could take this list
of integers and strings,
and masquerade it as
a list of integers.
The type system would
let you do that,
and it only if you actually
kind of hit one of these strings
unexpectedly that
things would go wrong.
We can't let you
do that in Dart 2
because we want our tools to
be able to rely on the fact
that if you say it's
a list event, it is.
So you don't have to
use the types in Dart 2.
But if you use them, you
can't lie about them.
So for the most part, that
works out pretty well.
But we did run into places
where the libraries didn't
have the functionality
that they needed
to allow you to write
the code in the way
that we thought you should
be able to write it,
and this is a very
simple example.
So suppose I have
that mix list again,
and now I want to
filter it down.
I want to filter out everything
which isn't in an int
because I notice that there
is, in fact, a string in there
to get out an iterable event.
Well, the first thing I can do
is I can map a dot .where over
that.
This maps predicate,
and filters out
everything which doesn't
satisfy the predicate.
That's great, but unfortunately
the return type of .where is
still iterable of dynamics.
So we're back in the situation
of the static type system
not being able to tell what it
is that you want to pass in.
So the fix, the
workaround, was to map
over it again
actually witnessing
the fact that you
filtered things out.
But this is really unpleasant.
This is a workaround,
so this is a clear sign
that there was something
missing in the APIs.
And so we've been
fixing that, so we've
added to iterable a
whereType method, which
will do the filter and return
a new thing of the right type.
It filters based on
type, and so this
allows you to write this
relatively common pattern very
cleanly and very concisely.
So there's a number
of additional methods
and changes to
the core libraries
that you're going to see rolling
out in Dart 2 that are designed
around this idea of
how do you make working
with the core library
types in strong mode
very convenient, very clean,
very terse, very Darty?
So far, I've all been
talking about the work
that we've done to make
working with strong mode
and the sound type system great.
I've talked about how we've
been updating the libraries.
I haven't talked a
lot about the tools,
but you're going to
hear a lot about that
moving to the common front end.
So there's a lot of work
just around the type system,
but there's a few more
things coming in Dart 2
that I want to talk about.
And one of the reasons I want to
talk about them is they give us
a little bit of a hint,
I think, about where
we see the evolution of
the language happening
in the future.
So there are two things
I want to talk about.
I want to talk about
64-bit integers,
and I want to talk about
optional new and const.
In the original
Dart vision where
we were living in a
JIT compiled world,
it was a very
natural choice to say
we're going to make the native
integer type an arbitrary
precision integer.
So in the VM, you were able
to add numbers together
to your heart's content.
You didn't have to worry about
overflowing at 32 bits, or 64
bits, or 128 bits.
As much memory as you
had in your machine.
If you waited long enough,
you could eventually fill up
that memory with an integer.
And that works very
nicely in a JIT.
Because the JIT, most of the
time, you don't overflow.
So the JIT just
says, you know, I'm
going to just generate the
code for the fastpath then.
I'll check for the
error conditions.
And if they ever
happen, I'll bail out,
and I'll recompile all this
code and produce the worst case
code.
But most of the time, I'm in the
small compact native platform
code.
Unfortunately, that doesn't
work well on the web,
so the web has always lived
in the world where Dart
integers are actually doubles.
And unfortunately, it's
a little bit too costly
when we are compiling
to native ahead of time.
So when you are
compiling ahead of time,
you don't have the option of
bailing out and regenerating
the code.
You have to generate all
of that code ahead of time
as part of the executable
that gets shipped.
So that means that your
executable is bigger.
It means executable
is slower, and that's
a worse experience for our end
users at the end of the day.
So Dart 2 will have a default
integer type of 64-bits only,
and they will not
overflow into big ints.
This means we're able to
ship smaller, faster code.
So that's a benefit
to our end users,
but that's a big change
for the language.
It's not something that
comes up very often,
but it is something you need
to be aware of as developers
when you're working with Dart.
The second big change that
is happening in Dart 2,
this was talked about a
fair bit in the keynote,
but is around this
idea of reducing
the amount of boilerplate
and reducing the friction.
So if you look at this
piece of flutter code here,
there are a bunch
of keywords, which
are really sort of redundant.
So everyone in the world uses
the standard coding conventions
for naming constructors.
So if you look at this code,
it is completely obvious to you
as a developer.
There's very little additional
information given to you
by the fact that you
say new [INAUDIBLE]
new, new, new, right?
This is information that we
can statically infer for you,
and you as a developer can
easily infer in your head
just by reading just by
looking at the names.
So it really adds very
little value to anybody,
and so in Dart 2, we
will infer these for you.
You are welcome to
write them if you want,
but the system is able
to fill them in for you.
Edge insets has a
const constructor.
All of its arguments are const.
Therefore, we will just
make it const for you.
Anything that can't be const,
we will just fill in the news.
So this is just this pattern
of reducing the friction,
making things lighter
weight, making
it easier for you to quickly
get reliable code out the door.
So if I look forward to
where Dart is going to go,
I think both of
those two features
there that I just
pointed out give us
an idea of where we want to
see Dart going in the future.
So there are two things
that I think about.
One is making our
developers more productive,
and I think of that
as making Dart better.
So I want you guys to
be more productive,
so that you can ship better apps
more quickly to the end user.
And there are lots of things
we can do to make Dart better.
There are things like
generic constructors
that we don't have
yet to allow us
to take these relatively
untyped constructors
like from iterable, and
fill in more types on them.
And again, this allows us
to preserve types better,
and this allows us to
get better type inference
so that the users of your
APIs get a better experience.
We'd like to improve the
type promotion in Dart.
So Dart already
has a great feature
where if you do an instance
check on a variable,
we will use that information
to promote the type where
possible, so that you
don't have to recast it
or constantly recheck it.
This is something we can
make stronger and better.
And that will reduce the amount
of friction and boilerplate
that you have to write.
So this is something,
I think, we already
have a great proposal for
from members of the team,
and I really think we'll be
moving forward on quickly.
There's a bunch of
longer term stuff
that we're looking at as
we get more and more users.
It gets harder and harder
to evolve the language.
So I we're going to be
thinking very hard about what
we need to add to the language
to support further evolution
of the language and library.
We're very interested in
maintaining this ability
to work very cleanly with
untyped and typed code.
So I think we'll be thinking
about how the language can
support that very nicely.
And there's a lot of interest.
There's been a lot of
interest for a long time,
but there's a lot of interest
in non-nullable types.
This is a very hard thing
for us to do because there's
a lot of your code out there,
which is already written
without non-nullable types.
And so it's very hard
to migrate that code,
so we're going to have to
be very thoughtful about how
we do this if we do it in a way
that doesn't break the world.
But if we can do
this, I think there's
a lot of value we can provide
to developers, both in terms
of productivity by
catching nullers.
But also, in terms of
making Dart faster,
which is the other
thing that I think
we're really excited about
doing with the language going
forward.
We're very interested
in continuing
to push on this
idea of making Dart
a faster, better language for
shipping native apps and web
apps to end users.
So we want to get the code
size down smaller on web apps
and on native apps, memory
usage down, performance better.
Make better use of
multi-core processors.
Whether that's through better
isolates or other features.
Find ways to make the end user
product a better experience
by making the code
that is produced
by the Dart tools
better, so this
is something I think
we're very excited about.
The overarching
theme here is that we
want to make Dart the best
language for writing client
side code, and I think we are
committed to make that happen.
So if I look back at the past
sort of year or two of work,
there's really an amazing amount
of things we've done here.
We've taken this very dynamic
and fairly JIT focused
language, and we've migrated it.
We've evolved it forward to
being a fairly statically
typed language that's
very friendly to ahead
of time compilation without
eliminating the benefits of JIT
compilation.
We still have hot reload.
We still have fast refresh
cycles on native and on web.
So we've been able
to migrate this path
of trying to keep the best of
both worlds going by having
a very data driven process using
information we get by looking
at the huge corpus of
code that's out there,
and making sure that we fit
what people are actually doing.
When I look at what
we have done so far,
I look at it as we have
produced a great platform
for future evolution.
We have set a
baseline that I think
we can use to continue to
make the language better,
and we are committed
as a team to continuing
to evolve the language.
We are committed to growth.
We are committed to making
the language better,
and we want to make Dart
the best possible language
for writing client side code.
[APPLAUSE]